[Musique]
comment résumer cette participation au
56e salon international de l'agriculture
le mot qui illustre ce contexte c'est
énorme
plus de 630 3000 visiteurs 49 pays 4000
animaux 1400 éleveurs ou encore douze
mille produits des régions de france du
23 février au 3 mars au parc des
expositions de paris notre agriculture a
ouvert de nouvelles portes au premier
regard
j'avais très grand on se rend compte
qu'en fin de compte dans le domaine
agricole ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à mettre en place
il continue à mettre en place au final
et on voit que l'agriculture peut encore
avancer le département de la réunion
était au centre de ce hall 5.1 avec 600
m² d'un espace harmonisées pour 23
exposants ils ont fait le déplacement
pour se faire connaître faire connaître
la réunion et bien entendu vendre
montrer qu'on a des capacités des
compétences dans l'océan indien a créé
un produit de qualité à haute valeur
ajoutée parce que nous avions besoin et
nous devons vivre de notre travail
maintenant nos plantes sont dans des
amphis êtes on a réussi à mettre les
plantes médicinales de lille en format
infusettes pour doser dosé pour un litre
pour le premier salon le premier le
premier coup de masse alex gray
là-dessus de bien vendre
de rentrer à la réunion est boudée
[Musique]
à
d'autres chiffres pour comprendre les
jours qui ont suivi
cinquante sept visites officielles 65
délégations étrangères c'est le salon de
l'année on lui a rappelé combien combien
on compte sur notre état membre la
france pour défendre les intérêts de
notre pays la france dans la politique
agricole commune et surtout fier un
réflexe régions ultrapériphériques
c'est essentiel dans les discussions
difficiles qui s'annoncent au niveau
d'europe jeunes gens d'exploitation ce
qui est remarquable sont des gens qui
produisent qui transforme tout la plus
value est adapté entièrement à mal par
l'agriculture east idc comment ensemble
ont construit le nouveau modèle
insulaire de nouveau modèle agricole
insulaire
comment on se prépare et on est même
dans l'excellence par rapport à la
métropole à l'hexagone sur un certain
nombre de deux références comme le zéro
carbone le zéro déchet le 01 30
chimiques
comment on montre y compris d'ailleurs
au monde qu'en france gall meilleur et
que cette france là se trouve dans les
territoires d'outre-mer
[Musique]
[Rires]
de tous les âges seuls en groupe en
famille la foule a arpenté ce hall dans
une ambiance musicale
[Musique]
génial avec nous aujourd'hui moi juste
et en métropole ce jour-là à laitages
une table ronde permettait à tous de
donner leur avis sur la création d'un
modèle porté par l'enseigné leclerc en à
savoir faire et il faut le faire savoir
pour ça et c'est lorient qu'on va se
faire bouffer comme ça sont basses eaux
continuent à chaque bataille de son
petit poids gagner en flexibilité et en
enrayant vitesse de d'approvisionnement
parce que le coin que que souligné
nicolas c'est justement le problème
c'est comment être compétitifs par
rapport à nos concurrents on va dire mon
job est ce qu'aujourd'hui on triomphe
sans doute on est prêt et du faut
absolument qu'on arrive à vous apporter
ses solutions
or voilà une étoile est née à l'avant
sage mais à un moment donné
voilà plusieurs jours que des milliers
de visiteurs parcourent les allées de
cet événement international
alors comment choisir les bons produits
avec autant d'exposants ces concours
général agricole peut faire la
différence
aujourd'hui ça valorise vraiment le
produit les personnes intéressées ils
achètent en fait le produit qui est
médaille des femmes et des hommes de
talent était la thématique de cette
édition et on en a trois les confier la
réunion
allez on
lenoir comparative on est à 150 petits
producteurs qui cultivent de l'avenue en
se voir avec millions milieu forestier
vanille naturelle sans produits phytos
en engrais sans désherbant avec nous le
savons fait transformation de la réunion
et avec ça va à la recette c'est la
patience et le travail d une opération
pour notre île et de bonnes perspectives
pour l'avenir porter les réunionnais
vers l'épanouissement de leur projet est
une des missions du département de la
réunion mais vraiment réunionnais dans
l'âme on est fort on est solidaire et
quand c'est la réunion qui gagnent
forcément ce sont nos 23 exposants
ce sont les institutionnels qui portent
dans leur coeur cette récompense
[Musique]
m
bien des chantiers des difficultés des
enjeux sont en perspective pour notre
territoire
voilà pourquoi il fallait faire ce bilan
afin que comme pendant ce salon tous les
acteurs avancent ensemble sur l'avenir
de l'agriculture
notre avenir